all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back again with the power
rangers yes with shattered grit and uh i
woke up a little bit ago so you're gonna
have to excuse me my voice is a little
deeper than it normally is
but having said that uh so in the last
video that we had
we basically picked up on the idea that
the power rangers at least those in the
main power ranger universe were kind of
being led
to the command center of course by
fenster who was using the
i guess components body of alpha 5 to
trick the power rangers right and then
on the other side of the equation
we had billy and tommy from the main
power rangers universe who were in the
alternate reality of lord drakken and
then fighting alongside the coinless who
are basically that reality survivors of
what's left of the power rangers and
essentially humanity's rebel force right
trying to overcome and basically remove
the power of lord drakken where they can
when they can
and so kind of picking up with the the
power rangers in the main timeline here
for a second
of course again they're all wearing
green because they're tapped into the
morphin grid power of the green ranger
since it operates at a different
form more or less than the other power
rangers and so of course as they're
being led to this location
uh we as the audience know it's a great
big huge ruse as far as the power
rangers are concerned
they trust alpha 5 unquestionably and
that's gonna be one of the interesting
things that comes out of this is despite
everything that's happened
how they look at alpha 5 and how they
look at zordon is going to be changed
irrevocably in the aftermath of this not
in the most extreme way but in a way
nonetheless and of course we'll talk
about that once we once we cross that
bridge but
once they're led to this location of
course they're immediately met by all
these
goldars who have been created by finster
right by fencer who's basically being
used for the purpose of
you know taking these guys out now from
there you switch over to the alternate
reality right this is where things are
really really cool and in fact the
alternate reality is really
where the coolest things do happen at
this point in time now of course
the coinless main base of operations has
a giant force field around it but the
reality is this was always designed to
be a hidden place right it was always
designed to be a place where lord draken
never really knew where it was
the defense mechanisms here are okay
right there they could they they do what
they can where they can
but at the end of the day they weren't
really designed to face off against this
kind of onslaught
and that's basically what you're getting
here right like literally the power of
of lord drakken and all these ranger
forces that are laying an onslaught on
this thing
and destroying it in the best way or at
least trying to destroy it as fast as
they possibly can
and so what you get is this kind of
jumping back and forth between the
alternate universe and the main power
rangers universe right that's kind of
bouncing back and forth is happening
that basically
some of the shield generators are going
offline and that the only way to really
get them back is to actually go out
there and do it manually but if any of
the average people go out there they're
going to be totally destroyed so it
basically comes down to tommy and
and saba to basically get out there and
do what they can where they can
with regards to the main power rangers
universe they're being completely
overwhelmed by these goldars and the
length of fenster and rita have gone to
to make these goldars extremely powerful
is really cool because if you guys
recall under any normal circumstance
when they were fighting the putties or
different things like that they would
cut off an
arm rider they were pretty easily beat
up the putties were quite literally just
cannon fodder but with these goldars
they can reattach their limbs right it
takes a
lot of work to take these guys out and
the power rangers are being
overwhelmed very fast i mean to the
point that it's just good planning by
rita and fenster probably for the first
time in the entirety of their history
but the plan begins to go awry
when the power rangers basically just
start shooting holes in the wall in
order to create an exit for themselves
and that's when rita says fine then just
like send out the others right and so
what you end up finding out is that they
didn't just create these goldars that
are basically the size of power rangers
they created gold r's that are the size
of zorbs right so
they've literally covered all these
different bases and it's cool to see
that they were able to pull it off now
jumping back to this to this alternate
reality
the mastodon crew or mastodon guard
whatever you want to call them basically
the black ranger forces of lord draken
one of the things that's cool about this
is that lord drakken was exceedingly
intelligent in terms of how he assembled
all these forces together right
that it's not as though he destroyed all
the power rangers or pretty much all the
power rangers in this reality
and then took all took all their power
coins and then just gave everybody the
power of rangers
instead what he did is he split them up
into factions and so you have like
the red rangers which were essentially
the elite guard right like the best
fighters among lord draken soldiers
you've got the mastodon guys who are
basically
just your kind of foot soldiers more or
less the pink rangers are
even cooler than that but like all these
different forces kind of exist together
in these different ways
of course you guys will notice i left
out one particular power ranger and
we'll talk about him in a second but the
mastodon forces are really they're just
again just kind of shooting things up
but then of course you have
the red rangers you start to join into
the equation and that's when things
start to get a lot hairier
because where tommy and saba are able to
access the falcon zord and basically
offer a kind of a
compliment to essentially help these
forces offset you pick up with trini and
what you end up finding out here is the
one power coin right ranger coin
i always use them interchangeably but
the one thing he doesn't have right the
one ranger he doesn't have
is the blue ranger right access to the
triceratops and the reason why is
because if he had this seemingly
it would complete his ability to conquer
everything now in reality and what's
interesting about this
is it doesn't really seem like it made a
whole lot of difference right that
having the the blue power ranger coin
seems to more or less would basically
like complete the set
right but not having it didn't really
stop tommy from uh
basically helping rita repulsa conquer
what was what is basically the entirety
of the world
and then allowing lord draken to rule
over angel grove none of that really
seemed to stop it
the way it's initially presented here is
it really just kind of seems like well i
mean we've got a ranger at our disposal
the way this works though
is cool because what ends up happening
is trini says that that reality's
version of billy basically died
in order to keep the coin safe and then
gave it to her so she could keep it safe
what this
is is a back door it allows them to
access the morphin grid and then at the
end of the day
that's going to be the one thing that
basically saves them now back in the
main power ranger universe
of course they're still able to access
their zords that's one of the things we
talked about that even if they're not
necessarily tapped directly into the
you know pink ranger and red ranger and
all you know the normal morphin grid
just by virtue of being able to to back
end and use tommy's powers
still allows them to use their swords
the problem is that against the power of
these goldars it doesn't really make any
difference
and that's one of the funny things about
the different zords that were there is
it was always cool to see like the
saber-tooth tiger
or the the pterodactyl or the
tyrannosaurus or something like that but
when you really looked at it for what it
was
the zords themselves were designed to be
this thing where they were greater than
the sum of their parts right the
megazord is where they all kind of unify
and come together and that's why you
would always see the megazord fighting
against goldar and like the first
episode of power rangers or you would
see the megazord fighting against some
other foe out there right because
at the end of the day the the zords in
and of themselves while they were cool
unless you were dealing with like the
white tiger or the falcon zord or even
the dragon zord they weren't necessarily
designed to face off against a massive
credible threat like goldar
on their own and that's why fighting an
army of goldars leads to these guys
getting totally crushed
all the way to the point that trini is
actually subdued and basically taken by
goldar
and then you know brought directly to to
rita repulsa herself what you also end
up doing is again jumping back to this
alternate reality
and you've got tommy of course who's
piloting this uh this falcon sword which
is kind of cool he gets a few shots in
which is pretty awesome and then
suddenly you have the arrival of the
pink rangers who really seem to serve as
kind of the sniper squad but while all
that's happening lord drakken stows
aboard or basically gets aboard the
falcon sword and then it comes down to a
fight between himself and uh and tommy
and so that's the crazy thing here is
that the blue power coin right the the
triceratops coin the blue ranger coin
the thing they need
to be able to access into the morphing
grid the one thing that lord drakken is
missing
is really their only bargaining chip
here and so where the ship where the
falcon zord is taken down by the forces
of lord drakken and then tommy is you
know
you know temporarily kind of knocked out
you switch back over to uh to rita
repulsa basically dealing with with
trini and the whole idea kind of seems
to be like regardless of what you guys
thought was going to happen you guys
have lost
and that's what it shows here right like
this is an instance where rita has
won and it's kind of crazy to see that
right to see that like with the help of
lord drakken and even to a degree by
herself
rita overcame the power rangers right
something that we never ever thought
would happen but when you switch back to
this alternate reality the whole point
of this is that lord drakken basically
grabs tommy and says to all the other
members of the coinless who are watching
i'm gonna give you one shot right i'm
gonna give you one chance right
turn over the relic the the power coin
for the triceratops to the blue ranger
hand it over if you don't i'm gonna
start i'm gonna kill tommy and then i'm
gonna start killing everybody else
and that's one of the things that's kind
of crazy about this version of tommy
oliver and this alternate reality about
lord drakken is he's
ruthless man like he is extreme a lot of
you guys are probably asking
where's this reality's version of rita
repulsa you'll find out but it's nuts
man this guy is extreme
it's one of those kind of crazy things
and so while all that's going on you
have trini and you have billy who are
watching this whole thing unfold and the
question is what do we do and she's like
you got to turn into the blue ranger and
you got to go face him at the end of the
day though this is the biggest problem
is that billy realizes right off the bat
that's not gonna work
right like the blue ranger is not
powerful enough in and of himself to
overcome a guy who is a combination of
the green and the white ranger the power
level's just not there so he does the
only thing he can do when they go in for
the kill and he gets ready to kill tommy
from the main power rangers universe
billy steps up with the blue power
ranger coin and says we surrender
we give up right there's nothing we can
do here and basically starts handing
everything over with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace